how's it going bros my name is
[Music]
welcome to happy wheels 76 [ __ ]
episodes well there's probably people
who's done way more so I think we're
okay we're gonna check out the new
popular levels cuz they're always so
good like the levels are so original and
they're never just the same [ __ ] over
and over again
alright here we go we can build a sniper
rifle that's pretty cool
I want a bill I don't want really care
but okay well let's go with the a.m. P
maybe eight hour that we're gonna go
with the SVD cuz we're not a little
[ __ ]
and there's my rifle and now we get to
shoot it
alright how do I shoot it alright
objective kill this speech its ISM a
damn it I missed
damnit aim yes I got it
Wow amazing my new favorite level don't
you agree Bruce happy wheels make me oh
my god what is this where am I who are
you hello there sorry for scaring you
my name is lighter you're the one of the
few layers of every day I need you to
defeat a leader and put an end to this
urge follow me alright here we go oh my
God look at that face look what the [ __ ]
are all these things
[Music]
okay [ __ ] is this I like it give it give
it again give me a little holy [ __ ]
alright alright alright alright
maybe you can give me like a sick okay
okay okay okay he got me right in the
ass
Segway what are you doing Segway woo
adventure forever without my feet is
your slashing position burpees mic
position people call me a handicap I'm
not a handicap segue in peds go in
adventure what the [ __ ] go forward
Jesus Christ yeah yeah yeah that's a
good segue isn't it
Oh God got me right and detect in there
oh I have to wait on the platform and
all you push the platform what a douche
oh snap oh oh my god oh my oh my god
I've to die
Oh God ah that was so close oh he got my
foot goddammit alright well let's go
down here you don't need a leg okay what
the [ __ ] is this
oh my god look at that face get it back
off there we go I'm gonna be a the first
pirate Segway man that has ever finished
a happy wheels level
are we good we good we can do it ah what
the [ __ ] he's fisting me I know he was
trying to fist me daddy
oh my god don't fish me bro
oh god I'm alive and still alive I look
at me I can dance all night I can dance
all day I can segue segue you have to
tell the King come back with this man
Segway Segway Segway
segue okay well this one is called
awesome run fold so it has to be awesome
right right gimme let me get better yes
Ted I love it so much
shake Dan as for me shake that ass can
we come on girl oh no my son anything
but my son my beloved blood oh no it's
so bad I'm so upset about this so upset
oh god there it is look at that [ __ ] boy
take your [ __ ] leg out of my [ __ ]
boy god damn it
I got disco arms and [ __ ] now whoo okay
keep going son okay Cohen this is not
what I wanted there's good Grassi
harpoon run a harpoon run and never done
when it earns before all right boy let's
do D holy [ __ ] I got [ __ ] oh love it all
right boy the time has come for you to
do this on your own go my son go I
believe it you go my son you're a
disappointment son go son go go son go
go he keeps going make me proud boy do I
look like a [ __ ] whale no your mom is
a [ __ ] whale I shouldn't be doing
this [ __ ] god damn I'll at least like a
dance now never mind
well at least I can explode you know go
gushed you did it guts my gosh [ __ ] yeah
well this map is sure is exciting
hello helmet
very exciting all right boy we'll go
there you go
Ernest did you change shut the [ __ ] up
you little [ __ ] I didn't raise a little
[ __ ] [ __ ] up yes you did look at me
god dammit you ruined my voice I hate
you with every piece of my bones what is
this [ __ ] level what is the point
secret spike fall what does I mean
jacksepticeye this level is for you [ __ ]
you whoever made this map don't you suck
a dick I can play this maps here look
I'll probably be the chair in that bed
jack ball look at that look look at [ __ ]
you're a jack
[Music]
pull this fat man iran/iraq oh oh boy Oh
what keep going
never give up on your dreams keep no
matter what pulls you back yeah I keep
pulling back harder come on oh how I
love it I love it
come up king of happy wheels baby king
of happy wheels yeah all got my arm I
don't need it anyway I don't need it I
don't need anyone my life is empty
ah what are you doing trying to show me
off you piece of [ __ ]
come here hard goddamn I lost my other
arm oh I love it though Oh
super mega hardcore that's what my mom
said I think that's our porn site that's
disgusting
god damn it IRA - OH
you beat me to it well played well
played arm all right press we're gonna
have to end that episode there if you
had fun I had fun don't you like having
fun leave a like and I'll see you in the
next one as always stay awesome bros
[Music]
well I've always liked green just like
your mom's ass heyo all right so now I
can
[Music]